when does taxation become immoral when  does taxation become immoral correct  I suppose at any level taxation could be  moral or immoral and it's up to us in  our Prudence to to come to some sort of  agreement about that but as to your  question about the present state of  Taxation it's much much too high there's  just no question about that the church  takes 10 percent the mob takes 10 the  federal government especially now that  you can't deduct state and local they're  taking 50 percent of your money in some  cases  it's a lot give me give me back the  mafia in the church are you kidding me  compared to Joe Biden and the 87 000  armed IRS agents that he's going to send  to our doors  me and you